disgusting no no no
no no i don't think i have bad breath
but like everyone kind of does
a little bit right apparently a
significant amount of
bad breath actually comes from bacteria
that is made on the tongue
and not on your teeth when you brush
your teeth you're only doing part of the
job which is where this guy comes in
this is a tongue scraper and it is
supposed to remove the grossness
from your tongue i recently came across
it through a tick tock and i thought to
myself hmm my breath could probably be
better i've also sent these to some
co-workers and they
are going to give you their thoughts
viewer discretion is
definitely advised for this one you're
going to have to look at this
a lot i'm getting some goldfish
so that when my tongue is disgusting i
can be like oh it's because i just ate
as opposed to having like a disgusting
tongue that makes sense i'm so excited
because
i personally love gross things i love to
go on youtube
and watch people pop other people's
pimples
and i also love to see when earwax comes
out of someone's ear
i think my dental hygiene is like good i
brush my teeth i floss
every day i mean what more could you ask
suppose you could use a tongue scraper
that's more you could ask tongue
scrapers
never really been on the agenda it looks
like an evil surgical instrument
from the past so let's see what's up
with my tongue
okay well the tongue is disgusting so
we're gonna get up close and personal
[Music]
oh yeah if you're worried about gagging
start at the middle of your tongue i'm
not worried
ah maybe gaga but
[Music]
that's nasty that just came off of my
tongue
absolutely not you're straight up have
like liquid coming out hold on
ah absolutely not
are you kidding me right now are you
kidding me just leaves my tongue dry
i'm getting some stuff off here
uh i went too far in
ah if goldfish sees that this video got
out
it'd be game over for them because this
is disgusting and i am blaming this on
goldfish
aggressive tongue scraping okay so this
is for sure
like that worked that is straight up
gunk
so now let's see what happened
[Music]
overall i feel like my breath is a
little bit more fresh
um of course i still need to floss and
brush my teeth
my mouth does feel a little bit cleaner
now that it doesn't have that gross gunk
in there i feel like i could just keep
doing this for hours and more stuff
would come out it's like when you're
popping a pimple and you're like how is
there more stuff in there
like legally how is more stuff coming
out overall i'll say this thing worked
pretty well
my mouth definitely feels cleaner and
the saliva that came off of my tongue
was not
the clear saliva that i think of there
was definitely some plaque buildup
on there i will definitely be
incorporating this into my
personal care routine will i continue
doing it
you know what i have the product now i'm
gonna give it a go
i will continue doing it
[Music]
you